we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P thank your lucky stars
every day you're not Dave Pacman but you
can call Dave packman at 2192 David P
here is a caller who learning that I
will soon be in Florida
is asking whether this is the trip
during which I will eat fast food with
Farren cousins listen to this
hi David
um on the bonus show on Monday yes
um you mentioned going to Florida
perfect I just want to remind you if you
happen to see Farren then I just want to
remind you that like a year ago you said
he would uh
I think he said he would get you
McDonald's Burger King
I think it was just a fast food Burger
basically but I remember the night he
tweeted at you so I just want you to
recall that
um you two would be good hosts if
there's ever some sort of progressive
equivalent
to
you know cpack or something but yeah I
would love to co-host something with
farron so listen uh I am going to be in
Florida but I'm not going to see Faron
on this trip I'm going to be in a
different part of Florida doing some
appearances including on the Patrick
David show and with Anthony pompliano of
course all assuming it doesn't get
canceled as I told you Lex Friedman
canceled our appearance together last
week a very very last minute I I'm
hopeful that next week's appearance is
in Florida
don't get canceled my goal is not to
have any fast food while I'm in Florida
I am looking forward to the restaurants
great food scene in the Miami area so I
am looking forward to that many
Argentinian restaurants I'm going to be
going to Argentinian restaurants getting
some empanadas getting a little milanesa
it's all happening but I hope not to
have any McDonald's or Burger King or
anything like that is it conceivable
some kind of emergency could take place
and I end up having no choice but to get
a Double Whopper it's possible it's
possible but let's hope it doesn't
happen on today's bonus show Kevin
McCarthy blocking swalwell and Schiff
from the Intel committee we will talk
about it when I'm joined by producer Pat
journalist deaths jumped 50 in 2022 led
by Ukraine and Mexico and Netflix is
finally they're really doing it this
time they're going to crack down on
password sharing and we will talk about
how and why and is it fair and all these
different things get instant access to
the bonus show by signing up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get yourself a
sizable discount and it will be maybe
the best bonus show we've ever had oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad that's right
money will be made on today's bonus show
and I hope Alex I really hope it is not
money that that I ever end up having to
pay someone in a defamation settlement
let's hope that that's the case we'll
see you then